imagine a soldier the size of an insect
we ultimate secret weapon I am a
tremendous fan of imax a tremendous fan
of the whole vision howard said it Scott
I've been watching you for a while
you're different I mean I'm involved and
I can't wait to see this thing on imax
skillful agile fast when i go to a movie
i want to have an experience I want to
like I'm gonna have an emotional
experience whether it's laughing or
crying I want to be moved and the imax
format it's just larger than life and
it's so sharp and it's so big and you
really feel like you're there what do
you want me to do I want you to break
into a place and steal some stuff makes
sense so much of the action is about
playing with scale and so the bigger the
screen the better you tried to hide your
suit from me now it's gonna blow up in
your face and destroy everyone you care
about the CGI special effects especially
with the ants is gonna be massive
with imax you're going to go into like
this teeny tiny world and it's
mind-blowing we go into this Microverse
and you put it on the imax theater
there's nothing that compares to that
that's the choice did I tell anybody
you're a fool see the movie any other
way when ant men goes small and suddenly
the entire world is huge we'll just be
amplified by the fact that this huge
screen that is all encompassing and
you're gonna feel what a man feels this
would be a movie that I would insist on
seeing in imax one of the big things for
me in the movie is when he shrinks down
I want to bring the audience down in
that world I don't want them to be
immerse and it's got to feel real and in
imax it's insane did you think you could
stop the future
you're just a thief no I'm ant-man I
know wasn't my idea